jeudi 21 octobre 1965
la nuit tombe sur fort de france un
lycéen de 17 ans sort du bus qui le
ramène des cours pour rentrer chez lui
dans le quartier de sainte thérèse
j'entends le feu et je vois un petit
mouvement de foule et une sorte de masse
jeudi est accroupi au pied d'un poteau
et j'entends y at il ou elle est mort ni
tient juste marni vient de s'écrouler
sous les tirs des gendarmes ayant pris
trois balles il est transporté dans un
état très sérieux à l'hôpital clarac la
fin de la cavale et d'une aventure qui a
tenu toute la martinique en haleine
pendant près de deux mois
la vie de celui qui allait devenir
l'ennemi public numéro un
bascule le 2 septembre 65 condamné deux
ans plus tôt pour des vols de pièces de
voiture le jeune marni 22 ans profite
d'une permission pour demander des
comptes à ses anciens complices armés
d'un fusil ils seront à schoelcher et
commence à semer les morts et les
blessés souvent des proches de ce qu'ils
cherchent réellement victime collatérale
de sa soif de vengeance
trois personnes sont tuées dont un
enfant de deux ans et demi fils de l'un
de ses complices présumés
le quotidien france antilles lancé un an
auparavant
suit la cavale de mardi au jour le jour
avec noorani c'était au quotidien on
s'arrachait journal ont débuté à la
radio également pu en avoir un peu plus
pendant six jours tous les gendarmes et
policiers de lille sont à ses trousses
on a vu marnier achète cher au lamentin
aux marins jusqu'à son interpellation à
la faveur d'un accident de voiture le 8
septembre sur la route de redoute à fort
de france
le feuilleton a tenu la population en
haleine la foule se rassemble près du
commissariat pierre juste marni en
profite pour transmettre un message aux
journalistes une lettre dans laquelle il
explique ce qui a motivé son action un
courrier signé du surnom qu'il s'est
choisi la panthère noire
il ne restera pas bien longtemps sous
les verrous du 118 rue victor sévère le
10 octobre
moins d'un mois après son arrestation il
parvient à se faire la belle et une
nouvelle cavale commence mais une partie
de l'opinion a déjà pris fait et cause
pour celui qu'elle considère désormais
comme un héros du peuple
or ni ont représenté par ailleurs un peu
robin des bois et ça je crois que
s'impliquant bientôt nombre de personnes
il y avait dans le quartier un seul
téléviseur et nous avons eu l'occasion
de voir maroni je tenais aussi sur cet
écran alors qu'ils étaient recherchés
par toutes les forces de gendarmerie de
lille c'est un petit moment et puis
repartir mais à aucun moment oui oui oui
tous les gars mais savait que c'était
mardi mais aucun moment il ne serait
venu à l'esprit d'un des jeunes d'aller
dénoncer marne et 7 secondes chasse à
l'homme va durer 11 jours jusqu'à ce
qu'un gardien de prison dont l alerte le
21 octobre après avoir reconnu le
fugitif devant une épicerie de sainte
thérèse
ce quartier populaire de fort de france
dans lequel il a ses habitudes son
interpellation plus que musclée entraîne
un véritable soulèvement populaire
ils ont commencé à tirer peu partout des
toutes sortes de choses cailloux des
baux longs des biens volés en
d'identifier j'ai balancé grenades
lacrymogènes les gens voient des pierres
et ça a duré toute la nuit après trois
jours d'émeutes qui paralyse
fort-de-france et font un mort et 40
blessés le calme revient mais craignant
de nouveaux débordements les autorités
décident d'envoyer discrètement marni en
france il est jugé quatre ans plus tard
à paris est condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
la panthère noire ne reverra la
martinique qu'en 2008 43 ans après ces
crimes
pierre juste marni alias la panthère
noire descendre la passerelle
vêtu d'un costume noir et d'une chemise
blanche il a 65 ans il souffre de
troubles visuels
ils avancent difficilement guidé par un
policier
marni va se battre pendant trois ans
pour tenter d'obtenir une libération en
vain le plus ancien prisonnier de france
n'aura droit qu'à six heures de liberté
le temps d'une permission et d'un bain
de mer en compagnie de ses proches
vous avez jean georges et fidea mois de
plus d'enfants sont chevronnés
il sera évidemment je suis très fier à
30 ans vient juste marié finit par
abandonner sa lutte en mettant fin à ses
jours dans sa cellule du centre
pénitentiaire de ducos le 7 août 2011 au
lendemain de son 67e anniversaire